من المعروف النظيف في المناعه معرضون
للامراض وبات لدينا اليوم دراسه الشامله
حول مناعه سكان الشرق الاوسط هذه الدراسه
تظهر نتائج اللافته جدا البيانات عن ضعيف
في المناعه في العالم العربي غير متوفره
ما يترك الملايين منهم عمر دار الخطر بحسب
الدراسه التي نستضيف اليوم الطبيب الذي
اجرها الدراسه الجديده التي تحمل اسم
المرضى المنسيون تهدف الى توفير حمايه
افضل للمرضى المعرضين لمخاطر عاليه في
المستقبل تعد هذه الدراسه الاولى من نوعها
في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
تحدث عن ارتفاع غير مسبوق في عدد المصابين
بضعف المناعه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
والشمالي افريقيا هل من احصاءات محدده ومن
هم اكثر الفئات المتضرره
اليوم مصابين بنقص المناعه في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط ولكن هذه الدراسه بدات تسليط الضوء
على هذه الفئه المنسيه
تسبب نقص المناعه ايضا امراض مزمنه همم
مثل همم الجهاز الهضمي
الجهاز العصبي يتطلبون ايضا ادويه مثبته
للمناعه حتى يكون التحكم في المرض ايضا
المرض السرطان والمصابين بامراض السرطان
الدم والمرضى الذين خضعوا لزراعه اعضاء
ايضا هم يستخدمون ادويه تؤدي الى تثبيت
المناعه وهؤلاء كلهم يعني معرضين لخطر
الاصابه بفيروسات وبكتيريا كثيره وطبعا
احنا في ظل الجائح العاديه
نعمنا في منطقه الشرق الاوسط والشمال
افريقيا تحديدا ارتفاع عدد الاشخاص
المعرضون الاصابه بيعدوا شديد وغير قادرين
على تكوين مناعه قويه رغم التطعيم ما
السبب في ذلك طبعا
في المناعه لما تعطي الشخص الطبيعي تلقيح
او لقاح الحب 19 فالجسم يقوم باصدار او
يعني انتاج الاجسام مضاده ولكن هذه هذه
الفئه المصابون بنقص في المناعه او النزول
في المناعه الجسم لا يستطيع انتاج هذه
الاجسام المضاده فيكون مقدره لديهم على
مكافحه البيوصات بشكل عام وخاصه والكبدنا
اقل من الاشخاص العالميه الطبيعيه وهذا تم
نشره في مجلات علميه كثيره جدا وهو معروفه
لدينا في المجال الطبيعي